hello freak [ __ ] fact it's kind of
about finding whatever works best for
you right right exactly for me I like
Sprint's I'm like a very explosive
fighter and also I have endurance he was
like I did the vo2 testing it's actually
I tested as a cross-country runner I
hate running
I ran on the results you know so but
more I feel like I do better at
sprinting in long-distance but it's
crazy like what you have to be in shape
for going you know to fight for the cage
like you have to be great wrestling
conditioning boxing conditioning those
are all different conditionings like
yeah a boxer comes in and wrestles he's
toast in a minute it's right
you know sometimes dressers the same
thing they go in there their boxer just
a composure
you know it's what made whether I'm
sorry what Conor said right after
Mayweather he's yeah shots were nothing
he didn't you know it was just the
composure yeah I was logged in
he's just so efficient too and he knew
the Conor was gonna fade because Conor
was relying so much on explosiveness and
tents and so there I thought Conor did a
good job of Slade nice and flowy and
everything but here's here's the truth
it's like if I were to take a pretty
good high school wrestler or like even
like a really good high school wrestler
and put them against an Olympic gold
medalist like like a high high level
high school wrestler versus an Olympic
gold medalist I mean there's gonna be a
difference but when when the fatigue
cracks a little bit it starts happening
a little bit one guy's gonna keep
composure completely and the other guy's
gonna have a little bit of a of an
opening and the other guy will be able
to to isolate that and I think that's
what happened with with a fight and I
figured that would happen I just didn't
think that Conor would do that well the
whole fight until it happened you know
he was doing awesome it makes me wonder
like how would he have done if he had
six months to prepare how good would he
have done if he got in good shape he
might have been able to make it to the
12th round I think either way the the
more loose Floyd got the more he was
gonna start landing shots he's just a
far better boxer he's a specialist you
know I don't think it was I don't think
it would be it's about getting in shape
necessarily because Conor had to be an
amazing shape he's already a world
champion then he's got this big
opportunity that's what I always tell
the guys also it doesn't matter what
kind of shape you're in
being a shape only means you can do more
until you get tired mmm I think the
better shape you're in he would've kept
doing more doing more doing more and if
he wasn't able to finish him you know
what I mean like cuz Floyd was letting
him do more when I mean wasn't letting
um he was wasn't letting him necessarily
but who's taking rounds off for sure
Conor blowouts managing so it's it's
like the better shape you're in the more
you're gonna output until you get tired
but if you're trying to [ __ ] win
you're gonna be you know you're gonna be
putting it out putting it out putting
out I think he would have been able to
do more until he got tired but the
fatigue would have set in we other way
[Applause]
[Music]